this is the drop o matic we needed
something could drop all five phones
simultaneously so I made this here on
Battle Damage we don't only love
destroying technology we also love
creating it which is why instead of just
dropping the iPhones by hand we
custom-built this crazy thing you're my
first printed prototypes this is the
bottom and this is the little slide
mechanism which will release the
trapdoor I was gonna have just one big
butt in the center but I realize you
really want to kind of hit them with
your thumb so you can see it spotting
out the basic shapes you can get an idea
what don't like now it's gonna start
very slowly putting down those base
layers prints gonna take about five
hours
printing the biggest piece we've got
some of the phones in this is sort of
the moment of truth two out of three are
too tight so well maybe we'll get in
there with some sandpaper and see we can
do this is what I got so far which is
really good progress I don't use Arduino
enough to really like know how to code I
just like copy paste so basically I got
right here is you know you press this
button and that opens and closes here's
a basic mock-up of what it's going to
look like these will be our LED status
lights our microcontroller and under
here it's a little printed spot for the
battery as you start up sequence this
there's automatic shut yeah okay here's
all the generations of iPhones and we're
seeing what fits this must be good seems
to be good iPhone 4 Oh
iPhone 5 iPhone 6 pretty good toaster
man see if they'll fall ready here you
go one two three if you thought the drop
ematic was cool give this video a thumbs
up and click the link on screen to watch
the iPhone episode